get your act together please and clean
up your work spaces because we have an
all-time great waiting for us on the on
the mercedes-benz vans phone line he is
a hall of famer and his documentary on
his uh life and career facing nolan was
just screened at south by southwest
baseball hall of famer nolan ryan here
on the rich eisen show how are you doing
sir
good rich how are you i'm doing great i
am just doing great man i'm such a i'm a
big fan i'm a big fan so i'm i'm honored
that you have uh called into the show
you bet so what about this documentary
uh
appealed to you about uh having it made
and doing it paul and ryan well to be
honest with you i
really had put it off and i'd had a few
requests but uh there wasn't something
that uh i really
cared about doing and my children and my
wife
kept on me about they felt like i needed
to do it
for my grandchildren and and so
i finally can sit into it and uh
and i feel like the guys did a really
good job on it i was real pleased with
the results
so um when was the first time you
realized you could throw a baseball
really well nolan
you know
growing up and playing little league i
couldn't
throw any harder than anybody else i
could probably throw the ball further
than anybody but not harder and
after my sophomore year in high school
when i went out for the baseball team
that spring
i hit my last growth spurt and when i
went out for the team it was like i had
somebody else's arm and i don't have an
explanation for that
but that's the first time that it showed
that
that i had this
gift
and
what was it like
being on the mets when you first started
in the late 60s the 69 mets the famed
mets team that still resonates today
with siever
on the mound and kuzmin and the rest of
that staff and you were in the pen if
i'm not mistaken correct nolan
what had happened was i i was in and out
of the rotation but uh
i had a military obligation
that was back in the days of the vietnam
war and i was in a top priority reserve
unit in houston so every other weekend i
had to fly to houston
for my reserve meetings and because of
that
i never was consistently in the rotation
and so when
when i wasn't in the rotation they'd put
me in the bullpen and
yeah i uh
the biggest thing challenge i had was i
had control problems and i didn't really
understand my delivery and what i had to
do
until i went to the california angels
and i was
then my obligation with the
reserves was over and i started pitching
every fourth day
huh so did uh what was it like being a
teammate deceiver
nolan tom had a big influence on my
career because he was the first
player i ever played with that was as
focused as he was
and his intent was to make baseball a
career and and he approached uh
approached his career that way and and
so i being a teammate of his and being a
friend of his
i was able to observe him on a
day-to-day basis and it definitely had
an influence on me
toughest hitter you had to face early in
your career was who
no one oh back in those days because i
was
really just a fastball pitcher
was willie mccovey well he started a
little left-handed power hitters that
were good fastball hitters and then
obviously it
changed later in my career when i faced
the
left-handers that didn't swing in bad
pitches didn't help you out the people
like pete rose and george brett rod
crews tony gwynn those kind of guys what
about clementi what about him lemay
was a very aggressive right
right-handed hitter and if he left the
ball up out over the plate he and hit
he'd hit the ball at any part of the
ballpark and was a fun guy to try to be
to pitch to because it was such a
challenge
and uh what about rose walk me through
pete rose's face
[Music]
rose i thought was a better off speed
hitter than he was a fastball hitter but
he had the unique ability to foul off
pitches until he got a pitch that he
could handle
what was the guy that you were most
pleased to have hit
nolan
oh i don't know i hadn't really ever
thought about that no that's why i ask
it
what do you got
when we're like okay you know what i
didn't mean to hit him but i'm glad i
did anything like that yeah i came close
to him
no but nobody there's nobody just leaps
to mind from back
that that's uh that's all water
underneath the bridge from back in your
day
much so you know your pitching's changed
considerably that don't pitch inside
much anymore and and uh
when you came up to the big leagues it
was understood that you were gonna pitch
inside so who's the guy that um that i
guess showed you or when you were coming
into the league or growing up to that
pitching inside was crucial
which was that
i had an influence on me was don
drysdale he was an announcer with the
angels when i was there
and uh
on road trips on
whether we were in the plane or the bus
we'd sometimes get to talking pitching
and talk about uh setting up hitters and
how you approach them about pitching
inside
you know it's pretty incredible nolan
ryan here on the rich eisen show again
uh facing nolan is a documentary that
you should all seek out it just got
screened at south by southwest
and it's uh on the upcoming festival
circuit right here on the rich eisen
show so um it's amazing you know you're
in the guinness book of world records
for uh breaking a hundred miles an hour
that's still in there and it seems
you know
if you don't throw a hundred miles an
hour or don't have the opportunity to
touch 100 miles an hour you you're not
going to be coming out of somebody's pen
these days it seems like everybody
fourth fifth sixth seventh eighth ninth
innings
openers instead of uh starters it just
seems that that's the the state of major
league baseball what do you think of
that development about the sport well i
i'm not a big fan of the way they are
using pitching in the big leagues
nowadays and the fact that starters are
going four or five innings because i
really feel like that you're under
utilizing those people
and they're usually your best pitchers
and so uh
why wouldn't you try to get more innings
out of them and and put less pressure on
the bullpen
and then the the thing that they want
out of the bullpen is to bring big
upside arms in
and just have them throw the ball by
people and pitching inning and uh
you don't have long men and and you have
a
combination of
uh
short relievers and
when i was pitching on a four day
rotation in california we had nine
pitchers on our pitching staff and now
you have 13 to 14 on major league staff
and it's because of how they use them
well what if somebody had come uh up to
you on the mound
and you know it's
top five right it's top five you're not
even yet through
um you know an official if you will
start to try and get a win
tie game
guy on first but it's the third time
through the order and the lead off guy
comes up and the manager asks for the
ball because they see the numbers that
third time through the order is not your
strong suit what would you have said in
that regard
well you know obviously that wasn't our
mindset in those days and when you
started the game
we uh our intent was to finish a game
and i i think i had two years in a row
and i'm doing this all memory and i
don't have a memory like like pete rose
does so i can't recall pitches and stuff
but
i want to say that i completed 26 games
two years in a row
and nowadays you wouldn't even have
the
26 complete games in all the major
leagues
why
you know is it just i i
i it's just i mean obviously you've
spent some time uh in
baseball recently um
what was the conversation in these front
offices on this business you know
analytics has taken over the game and
and
they're right about the third time
through the order the the hitters have a
better opportunity
and a better feel for what you're
throwing what your pitches look like and
and it increases their chances of
getting a base hit
but uh if you have
could you picture taking tom seever out
in the fourth or fifth inning i don't
think so
i i i hear you so did you ever say
something in the room and um and and
and i guess got into some sort of a
debate
well when i worked
uh for the astros they didn't include
players um
ex-players in those discussions because
the general manager has never played the
game and the analytical people have
never played the game
and
what we thought went totally against
what
uh
their numbers were telling them so they
didn't want to hear it
so what would your suggestion be if you
nolan ryan could wave
you know
a nolan ryan wand um
and uh and say this needs to be
implemented in major league baseball
what would it be
well i would honestly use my starters
longer but you know with analytics you
can evaluate uh whether a player the
third time through the lineup pitcher is
he's losing his stuff his spin rate
isn't as good and movement isn't as good
on his pitches and once that shows with
an individual then you can make that
change but
when you have people
and i'm going to use siever for an
example
the tom seaver pitching for you
you're better off
even if he doesn't have his quite as
good of stuff
uh in the sixth or seventh inning as he
had in the first or second inning he
still with the competitor that is it he
is and the ability to throw the ball
where he wants it is still your best
option
nolan ryan here uh on the rich eisen
show uh i i've waited ten plus minutes
to ask this question i think you know
what's coming but i'll do it anyway
uh the time where rob and ventura
charged the mound on you nolan
what what's your recollection of that
day in that moment when he charged well
there was a history between the white
sox and the rangers that year of kind of
bad blood we had a fight with them
earlier in the year
and uh
robin's first time up
at the plate i left the ball out over
the plate and he got to hit the left
field
and uh so the next time up i was gonna
pitch him in and i just got too far in
and hit him and uh
i think because of uh
the fact that we had had a fight earlier
and there were hard feelings between
those two teams he just reacted
well i mean you were 20 years his senior
nolan so were you surprised that he was
actually charging the mound on you
yeah i think anytime
that happens you're surprised by it but
uh mainly from robin because that wasn't
his nature right at all was it your
nature to give noogies to the top of his
head no one
well i guess it was
you know you just react to the situation
and
as i've said you know when i go
somewhere it's about the third
third question that comes up is about
robin ventura and i always said you know
of all the things that had happened in
my career that's the thing i'm
remembered for no i mean it's it's
definitely you know somebody who's 20
years somebody's senior
um whooping uh somebody like that will
will always leap out and then it's
somebody of your stature and robin's a
terrific
player in his own right and a really
great guy he was definitely out of his
character he's nice as he can be and and
like i say i think is just
the moment
you know i'm sure it was and so how many
people charge the mound on you in your
career how often did that happen who
were the others
willie mccovey and uh dave winfield
what happened what happened with those
moments what happened with those guys
well in willie mccovey's case it was in
spring training and
and uh
i think he just reacted just like robin
did and with dave winfield it was his
free agent here with uh
um
san diego and uh
our book on him was to pitch him in and
stay in on him and so i i had thrown
three fastballs in on him and he just
i think was so frustrated because he was
in a mini slump
uh that he just reacted
did you get them too
did you send them home too no well
those other two guys are a handful
that they are have you ever spoken to
them about it in cooperstown any of
those moments no one you know uh
uh
i'd seen uh
willie
several times and obviously there
weren't any hard feelings and then dave
i seem periodically and i feel the same
way about it just
it's just the moment of being
competitive so who's the uh pitcher uh
nolan that you'd you'd you know put
hard-earned american dollars down to
watch pitch
today i like jared cole i think that uh
he's aggressive he pitches well he has
good stuff and uh he's a competitor okay
when was the last time you got on a
mound
a long time ago
you know uh
i could still throw for a long time
after i retired but those days are
definitely over okay so when was the
last time you touched a hundred when was
the last time that happened for you it
was a long time ago too
yeah i know but i mean like if i put you
on a mound right now nolan what like
what what what what do you think you can
get up to
what do you think oh i don't think the
radar would read on it oh come on
come on now come on now you gotta
realize i'm 75 years old i know so
that's that's just a number that's just
that's just a number
that's it i mean you could touch what
come on what you could touch 80 right
now you could throw your let's put it
this way you could throw your rage right
if we put you on a mound right now i
would like to thank
just trying to my son's just playing
he's a lefty he's just starting little
league right now so i'm just trying to
i'm gonna show him this interview later
on so you can well he you got him going
the right way and being a left-hander
when he picked a a ball up with his left
hand for the first time i turned to my
wife i'm like we are retiring 45 years
from now that is exactly right you know
uh congratulations on the documentary um
thank you i appreciate it and i
appreciate
you taking time visit with me absolutely
facing nolan.com is how you can get
information and updates on the
documentary facing nolan is the name of
the documentary um and uh
a pleasure i'd love to do this more
often if you're up for it nolan ryan
thank you rich yeah any time all right
that's nolan ryan everybody right here
on the rich eisen show hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here